[Music]
[Music]
there she is Miss America and all her
horn blowing are you drunk yeah you're
driving oh okay how are you drunk
already
you were taking forever so I just went
down to 7-eleven and made a Bloody Mary
it's just tomato juice and vodka it's a
good idea you have to finish all of it
before we leave
I mean it's technically a cloaking oh my
god but it's fine I know dude I left my
purse inside oh we have to go back and
get it we yes we I can't go back in by
myself now
[Music]
what he is such a nice place okay I'm
just and does he have a brother
oh he has those tiny little pre oranges
what is he a rich scientist don't eat
those
he's also an architect which means he he
designs buildings but okay a little
black back I don't know where I left the
living room it's [ __ ] we have a
situation
or should I say situation what have you
done
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh that's bad that's poor dear
little mmm Oh LC that's out that big
[ __ ] you're right
you have your main oh sorry I'm just
trying to [ __ ] help really
Ricky don't stop meeting a sex god okay
I appreciate your help you're welcome
but this is one of those opportunities
for you to think before you make a move
again you tell you get spread and wake
up a little even really did you and you
ready Oh
feels all right yeah let's get back on
track here did you check the bedroom no
I'm scared
okay that's the most obvious place it's
gonna be is this hit are you freaking
can be thinkin you get that my squadron
you take your hands up right now you get
back in this bed I never don't leave me
enough to begin with so I'm not taking
them off now wait what
hey don't write not today
why not the rock you're not emotionally
ready for a one-night stand
you're right I know okay no no you know
what I think you just want to go to bed
okay yeah that's fun he's cute just
basic cut Achilles could be mean to me
in the morning so I'm beating him to the
punch let's get my person get her not
all guys are [ __ ] I thought that
about Kenneth because he had a Jack
Johnson poster and look at what happened
Kate you need to learn how to trust
again
are you kidding me do you see this mold
I see it you need to take your pants off
and get back in this bed hey morning
good morning
how'd you sleep uh uh
stupid stupid dreams at dumb dreams hey
girl listen ah the rain looks like it's
gonna rain kind of you want some coffee
yeah coffee would be that would be great
sounds good hey don't forget
O'Leary's opens it too if you want to go
back and get your purse I left it at the
bar of course [ __ ] hey do you want
like a French press or espresso um us
our french fries
nice Express it is perfect like it all
right wait you know what though and your
products and music gotta start the day
with music yeah yeah we gotta thought oh
great
yeah I'm a singer what [ __ ] yeah take
that job off the floor but he had a
singer and I guess the next logical
thing to do would be to sing you a song
good yeah
maybe go straight then maybe go left no
your brother
laughs oh great it's locked the door is
locked
figure it
oh yeah thank you no let's play game you
close your eyes and then I will say hot
or cold and I will lead you to your
phone
challenge accepted great clear okay yeah
make sure I don't break anything of
course of course yeah you're going
you're going yes whoops hey guys close
part of the game no part of the game
yep you're okay go go warmer go go go
more about it you got it got it
boom boom everyone's got a fun actually
you got it so quick that's good teamwork
yeah yep alright so I'm thinking maybe
what if I put on some Hamilton or maybe
even some Miles Davis know what is yeah
that'd be good what the hell is that um
this wasn't dumpin doesn't even make it
your show oh who the hell is that
ah nothing that's where flirtation no
that's stupid that's a gum line what why
dumb this is my this is this is Claire
and she's a surprise from you gonna look
like a [ __ ] Claire wait what she's
never had a one-night here I am nervous
doin a nice song I don't know her and
I'm sure he's I think you okay I guess
also sense what's up what the [ __ ] is
going on you know what it's gonna be
honest with you I got nervous this
morning I don't have one-night stand
I thought you would be a dick I now know
that you're not so we're just gonna go
it's just eight why tried to sneak out
it didn't work okay this is weird but
why don't you explain it to me over
breakfast oh that is a great idea and
you know what I will drop you guys off
at a great breakfast place that I goes
right down the street
yeah sure Claire thank you yeah I'm
gonna go brush my teeth
okay you go ahead no you should not
drive but this is awesome taking over
home you can [ __ ] holy what oh my gosh
Oh
you damn it all
we can work on like yeah I know that can
we go to Taco Bell - [ __ ] -
[Music]
another dip left and falsely and so I'm
alone again I'm gonna drive a little ha
ha ha ha